[Applaudissements]
espace et technique
alors attention n'oubliez pas chez vous
de bien côté vos points chaque question
je vous le dis pour reconnaître vos
résultats à la fin puisque je vous
montrais la courbe dans un instant vous
allez voir la cour pour savoir où vous
vous situez vous dirai tout ça et vous
allez voir si vous avez un cuit si vous
êtes un génie lui même acuité élevé vous
avez un faible et je vous donnerai des
personnalités depuis traversé l'été
pouvoir au pouvoir vous comparez eu ici
comparer vous à des personnes qui ne
sont pas dans la wii réagir à ce tag et
mp qi bien entre chine
attention aux questions espacé volume
voici la parole à l'ofs quel volume
obtient ton une fois la figure plier ma
ds 4 d
[Musique]
quel volume obtient ton une fois la
figure car liés et donc gynéco vous
aviez dit l'a2 savais que ça n'est pas
la pana vous savez déjà chez vous vous
dites à chez les gens pour la fumée sont
dit c'est bon j'ai pas répondu comme
king kelly le dvd vous avez répondu quoi
la 4 way
maxime gagny la gâterie également jean
michel 4 ici quatre à quatre tout le
monde a répondu l'a4 et tout le monde a
fait une énorme connerie non non ce que
c'est la bonne réponse est loin de
doctor who were vous êtes merci calmez
vous avez répondu la catho oui je sais
qu'il est un petit peu tard pour vous
aider 22h22 après il ya balances ton
post mes fonctions dans laquelle vous
n'êtes pas chez moi la regarde n'est pas
mais si je sais je sais que vous êtes
avec moi tout le temps et c'est pour ça
que vous amuser mais j'adore cet
hémicycle est ma préférée de l'équipe ça
tombe très bien alors ce ton poste avec
une interview exclusive à deux des
frères des nouveaux jackson et ils sont
tous là ils seront tous là ça rigole
seront tous en interview je vous le dis
et nous dirons tout et on a des images
exclusives bien sûr aussi du
documentaire sur michael jackson peut-on
encore être fan de michael jackson on
aura le retour d'agathe au cou agathon
pnas bien sûr reprendre balances ton
poste après l'annonce qu'elle a fait sur
instagram et bien sûr on en parlera avec
elle on parlera de ses stars qui révèle
au grand jour leur maladie est ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre
oui est-ce que vous lier les mains je
voulais juste vous demander de faire
l'interview un peu un peu plus tard
qu'on est temps de rentrer chez nous
bien sûr mais on habille toi bien du
tacle de l'essonne du matin ça rentre
vite rentrer vite ça ça change pas ça
dort comme ça
mais attention deuxième question de
espaces et technique quelle forme
remplace le point d'interrogation
attention 15 secondes si égal à ce alors
as égale as
[Musique]
quinze secondes ça on adore ça en à nos
amis non mr ça je me suis pas trop vite
alors s'il vous plaît répondez wes qu'un
second dirais je vous le dis si vous
êtes chez vous il nous reste encore
cette question et vous aurez votre
clavier également gk répondu doc gynéco
moins qu'on annule de suite une réponse
gg j'ai opté pour la 2 j'emmerde mais à
2 à 2 c'est donc on sait que ce n'est
pas la monnaie c'est très simple
regardez ah oui si vous partez le vide
et d'un parallélépipède égal ce volume
là un volume plein fouet le cercle est
requis c'est donc calme un cylindre
arrière sert qu'au bout du compte
voilà donc c'est le 4 kelly b2b 10
bonnes réponses gilles verdez isabelle
bonne allure matthieu delormeau vous
êtes trompés ouais j'avoue que j'ai ri
paix mais moi j'ai isabel députée
marmonne peut-être mal à me la bonne
réponse l'annoncé là c'est vous qui
habitez toulouse
alors bien sûr c'était le cylindre blond
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle ça ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle et vous l'aviez
remarqué chez vous ce que je fais
pression c'est du balayage visuel du
balayage en coiffure du balayage visuel
vous l'avez remarqué chez vous c'est ce
qu'ont fait très régulièrement
voilà mais excusez moi c'est bien parce
que vous vous moquez de moi a servi sur
la tête de ma mère j'ai presque envie
lundi dans l'émission benhaim ou je sais
pas ou que vous me fassiez accueilli en
tête à celle ci tu viens un sur cinq
parce que là j'ai l'impression que vous
notez que deux mois mais qu'est ce qui
se passe n'est pas ce que c'est avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour vous et
dieu sait de l'admiration mais vous
comme comme vous connaissez toujours
vous commencez toujours pas c'est très
simple mais vous avez la fiche devant
les yeux oui en effet c'est très simple
mais peut-être qu'on aimerait vous voir
un jour de l'autre côté de la barrière
attention sur quelques photos peut-on
voir tube une main gauche la main avec
le dictionnaire la main avec les
baguettes la main sur la jambe ou la
main sur la télécommande
regardez bien essayé de trouver chez
deux mains gauches passé de ça c'est
compliqué ça c'est le genre de truc que
j'aime pas du tout à sa joie il faut
aller on va demander à dominique a vu là
une lada donc une fois de plus les
limites non sûr qu'elle soit en pension
voir une main gauche avec a répondu
castaldi bas une connerie l'a eu
c'est jean michel maire que réussie mais
là tu as une âme manuellement
3 pourquoi la 3 bat parce que j'ai mis
ma main sur mon genou puis j'ai vu que
c'était la gauche bien entendu il avait
elle n'est pas répondu mais si je me les
mettre là trois métros et un bus
mathieu très bonne idée merci bébé ouais
bah oui mais moi aussi
malheureusement c'est fera salle c'est
tout après le time i die dont tu te fais
la main de la serpent d'eau qui va
rendre la main sur la gueule c'était la
main sur la jambe
et oui la main sur la jambe et qui la
main gauche j'avais la réponse avec
brest 5 questions benhaim vous revenez
très fort et maintenant nos repas vous
benhaim revient très fort vous ne vous
restez où vous êtes bien entendu mais
naim est très bien valérie bénaïm et
très bon mathieu dans le monde on
revient quand même attention je vous le
dis lequel de ces vinyles tourne le plus
vite
attention gilbert montagnards florent
pagny me lady gaga the women babar trois
frites
sur lequel de ses vinyles tourne le plus
vite c'est par rapport bien sûr ben vous
avez vu c'est une foire rapport à la
forme
la grandeur des vinyles à moins 2 alors
le calcaire lequel tourne le plus vite
ce chiffre est simple oui
benjamin castadi wii 3ds leucate banon
vous êtes bouquet dans la musique vous
ai dit quoi le 3 est bien situé
[Applaudissements]
pour
c'est le 3 et wii le 3 puisqu'on avait
gilbert montagnards c'était bien sûr on
va skier
on va essayer
ni eau
et l'instant d'après ski
il avait fort en pandémie bien entendu
yeux quitte à tout prendre et mai
il démontre le
moi
mais c'est lui qui voit là bas nicolas
bouvard que j'en aie avait également
donc lady gaga poker face et chimène
baba
votre histoire
d'une part
oise
un petit peu mal au nez
entre nous
si votre mot merci voilà alors pourquoi
c'est lady gaga bien entendu parce que
c'est le plus bien sûr et le plus petit
donc fait plus de tours et donc pour ne
plus vite que les ongles elles sont une
réponse de tout le monde sauf gilles
verdez pourquoi pour chimène badi la
minul
ah bah je vous dis ce que j'ai fait at
il cédé facile attention il reste quatre
questions là laquelle de ces cuves se
remplira en premier la ce a joué chez
vous laquelle de ces cuves se remplira
en premier à votre avis une deux trois
ou quatre
m
une deux trois ou quatre allez c'est pas
ces trophées c'est une deux trois ou
quatre c'est pas du tout facile et
bizarrement non c'est donc qu'il est que
vous ai dit quoi
4 voilà quatre noms j'ai imaginé la
distance en fait je me suis dit que la
distance et la profondeur qu'elle se
rempliraient le sa première alors vous
avez dit quoi vous avez dit quoi jean
vila 4 la 4l iv de visibilité j'ai milad
la 2 parce que vous trouvez que c'est la
plus petite on va j'ai vu le piège moi
je me sens c'est la plus petite
alors je vais vous dire pourquoi ça
n'est pas la 2 la 3 et oui je vous le
dire c'est la 4c l'attaqué et la 4g
parce que la carte est celle qui est le
plus proche c'est ça un but de soly et
oui bien entendu les oui c'est ça je
regardais un accord voilà allaoui à la
voilà ah oui parce que ça serait voilà
j'ai compris ouais donc c'était l'a4 doc
gynéco m'avait fait complètement au
hasard mais pas reconnu la bonne réponse
quand même
il est bon ou remonte la 4a c'était la
bonne réponse gagneront vous aviez du
coin à 4 elles viendront et les
excellents mais attention à visualiser
mentalement c'est la 4 siens ouais bravo
quand c'est daniel vous le dites et
faites pas premiers visuels visualiser
mentalement cet itinéraire vous avez 10
secondes chez vous kelly doit se rendre
à la bibliothèque son gps lui indique
l'itinéraire suivant au deuxième
croisement aller à droite puis prendre
la deuxième à gauche alors 2e
franchement attention au deuxième
croisement à la droite que prendre les
pinceaux
oui on se trouve dans les questions
abondent où se trouve la bibliothèque où
se trouve la bibliothèque à votre âge il
était qu'elle se trouve où on parle pas
de la flèche x 4 oui on parle de la
flèche bien entendu on part pas de chez
nous
bon alors
vous rappelez où se trouve la
bibliothèque c'est important d'y aller
ouais c'est important d'y aller en bus
alors où se trouve la bibliothèque de la
cemac et les merdes à bon alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez répondu jean
eddy maillet doc gynéco vous a répondu
quoi la 2 ac faut enfin le retrouve
c'est bon on retrouve la personne et
lives et dvd vous ai dit qu'on allait me
jacquin la 3 puisque c'est vous qui
devez vous rendre à la bibliothèque et
la bonne rythmique là c'est ce qu'on
appelle la planification et la
perception vision spatiale fait très
souvent alors c'est très simple
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'ils disent est
d'utiliser au deuxième
au deuxième croisement aller à droite et
l'a3 tu prends de la deuxième à court 3
c'est la 3 voulu naître à tous et donc
l'arrêt sa première fois benhaim vous
avez de bonnes réponses et bien vous
avez dit quoi daniel alors moi je vais
faire
isabelle morini-bosc mais j'ai appuyé
sur quatre enfants sans trois donc et
cela fera après mais je ne sais pas si
ça va nous trouver de réponse sachez que
c'est jean michel maire et daniel moreau
et valérie bénaïm se tiennent à deux
réponses vous le dis comme ça on est que
savoir qui va gagner le test lui ce soir
ça joue entre les trois allez on les
autres ce sera pas cette année